[Music]
hi everyone is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new spider-man venom verse
Morbius stuff to talk about there are
some crazy sinister six Easter eggs on
the set of the Morbius movie that
they're filming right now with Jared
Leto so I'll explain what this has to do
with the venom movie in the venom verse
that they're creating with Sony's
universe of Marvel characters and how
they're handling the spider-man of it
all because there will be changes to his
comic book origin the same way that
venom changed that comic book origin for
the movie you may remember that Morbius
was supposed to be a character inside
Wesley Snipes Blade trilogy this is
actually the alternate ending to the
first blade movie where Morbius shows up
on another rooftop
I need to get back to the lab I'm gonna
cure him it's over
you keep with you
I've never felt better
besides as long as there's a war going
on I still have a job to do
then your bathroom plumb
[Music]
the reason why they didn't wind up doing
this is because the original director
left before the sequel was Mageia Mo del
toro came on he made his version of
Blade 2 and there was no Morbius so thus
Morbius did not exist inside the blade
series I do Marvel Easter egg videos
like this every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything it's only
gonna get crazier with Avengers endgame
at the end of this month and then
spider-man far from home this summer way
before the venom movie came out they
planned on doing a Morbius film and a
bunch of other big solo films for their
bigger characters they felt like could
turn into franchises there's a silk
movie that they're working on there's a
Night Watch movie that they're working
on there's a craven movie and there's
actually Craven stuff that's showing up
during the Morbius movie that's where we
get to the sinister six of it all in all
these Easter eggs that people have been
seeing on the set of the Morbius movie
so Sony's using these films to world
build the same way that it used iron man
Iron Man 2 to world build building up to
Avengers and there are other big
characters before they had the Avengers
team-up in 2012 there are a couple
bigger villains that are debuting during
the Morbius movie that I think will
continue on to other team-up films
they're filming in Manchester England
but they're making it look like New York
City so the actual plot of the movie
will take place in Manhattan New York
City there was a very notable Kraven the
hunter food service truck what the hell
is going on with that is Kraven now food
service person is this a front for his
family's business that allows him to
travel all over the world while he's
hunting things because his real family
business his legacy is passing on the
hunt but because we haven't seen Kraven
in any of these movies even in the MCU
movies yet even though they tried to put
him in the Black Panther movie for like
a brief second before a kill monger
became the villain of that it sounds
like Sony is actually gonna try and make
their Kraven the hunter spin-off or
they're just laying groundwork
world-building
to let you know that he exists and they
haven't cast an actor yet and he'll just
show up in somebody else's movie nearby
there was a silver sable beauty salon
there was gonna be a silver sable
spin-off movie that they were developing
there was a black cat silver sable
team-up movie but then they cancelled
plans for that and turned them into two
different movies so silver sable is
gonna be her own movie in black cat is
gonna be her own movie they haven't cast
any of those characters yet or announced
release dates for any of those movies so
don't worry about them yet but it's just
more world-building letting you note
that they're gonna show up in the
universe eventually there's another sign
here for the
million quote-unquote theater meaning
that the chameleon is a character that's
gonna pop up in this universe eventually
right now he's a rumored character for
spider-man far from home but they
haven't actually confirmed that you look
in the background here on this wall
there's some graffiti for Stan Lee's
famous saying excelsior so I'm not
expecting ten huge giant characters and
a whole bunch of sinister six people to
show up during the Morbius movie I think
they're just slowly world-building
but it does sound like Sony still wants
to do their sinister six spin-off movie
that they tried to do during the Andrew
Garfield era how many men did you have
in mind I want to keep it small
everything you need access granted
welcome mr. fierce was our first
volunteer Alexey sit savage currently
serving a life sentence he is most eager
to join us good
start with him you may remember the Drew
Goddard was the person that was trying
to work on that he still said that he
wanted to do it someday if Sony was
still gonna try and do it but in the
intervening years he signed on to do the
x-force film with Ryan Reynolds in the
Deadpool people so it sounds like that
will happen before we see him do any
kind of sinister six team up movie there
been a couple set videos from the
Morbius movie like I said it seems like
right now they're filming the action
scenes for the film after his
transformation it sounds like the
version of the origin story that they're
going with is sort of a combination of
the original comic book story and the
1990s animated series when Morbius was a
student at Empire State University
Crawford was right I took her serum too
soon what are you up to Parker's DNA I
will expose the neogenic surface he
debuted in the comics an amazing
spider-man number 101 in 1973 remember
Dracula vampires were huge in the 1970s
so Marvel wanted to get in on it he was
created by Roy Thomas and Gil Kane they
actually said that they wanted to do a
Dracula type character but Stanley gave
them the order that he wanted a costumed
hero so that's where they came up with
the idea to turn him into a vampire
using science instead of traditional
supernatural means he was named Morbius
after dr. Morbius and Forbidden Planet
but the characters face was modeled
after Jack Palance who in the 1970s
which is crazy popular in the comics the
reason he becomes Morbius is because he
has a rare blood condition that he's
trying to treat he uses vampire bats in
electroshock therapy to try and cure his
disease that's what turns him into
Morbius the version that the movie is
going with is very similar he still has
a degenerative blood condition like you
see these pictures of Jared Leto kind of
hobbling his way on crutches winds up
using his treatment on himself
accidentally turning himself into a
vampire he didn't really run into
spider-man in the comics until after he
became Morbius and came to America
seeking a way to cure himself of his
vampirism Curt Connors winds up
attacking him while in lizard form and
because it's the beginning of the
six-armed saga and spider-man is
starting to mutate they actually come up
with the idea that they might be able to
cure their mutations the Liz
and spider-man with some of Morbius
mutated vampire blood it was a very
brief plan crossover with venom
spider-man and Morbius in the comics for
a miniseries but the artists on the
title just got into a bunch of arguments
and they wound up canceling it so you
can kind of see how Morbius bite wound
up teaming up with venom inside the Sony
venom burs to defeat carnage or any of
the other bigger villains that they
surface like the sinister six now get
out of here and I will there's gonna be
carnage
the villain of this movie is gonna be
crown from the comics but it's gonna be
a Matt Smith slightly different version
of the character so they're gonna say
that he used to be his friend but in the
comics the crown character really didn't
cross paths with Morbius - way way later
so crowns origin in the movie will kind
of dovetail with Morbius he'll have the
same blood condition go through the same
transformation it'd just be a more
monstrous version of the Morbius
character it'll be like the venom in
riot characters during the venom movie
much more evil violent version of
Morbius that Morbius then has to take
down take down his former friend there
is a character called Emil Niko's in the
comics who's Morbius is good friend who
points at being his first victim they
might give that backstory to Matt
Smith's crown character they're doing
his love interest Martine Bancroft from
the comics pretty simple explainer there
I don't expect them to get too crazy
with her character because they've
already got all this other sinister six
stuff that they're teasing the other big
characters in the movie you probably
heard about are Teresa's character he's
supposed to be playing an FBI agent a
lot of people wondered if he'd be
playing blade but he's like no I am
definitely not playing blade in this
series so it sounds like Kevin Feige is
still keeping that character in his
pocket wherever he'll show up next but
let me know in the comments what do you
think about all these Easter eggs and
how long do you think it's gonna be
before they try to get Morbius in a
movie with venom my guess is right now
that unless a V Arad comes out and tells
us exactly when that it's gonna be well
after the venom sequel like it'll still
be several years before you see them all
on a movie together I know you're all
asking for more spider-man far from home
stuff there'll be more of that in and
around Avengers in games so no worries
and we'll do a new round of that imax
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video WonderCon is
happening this weekend so there'll be a
bunch of footage dropping I'll try to do
as many of those videos as possible but
click here for all my Easter eggs from
that brand new Avengers endgame trailer
and click here for my Avengers endgame
post-credit scene video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
- see you guys tonight
[Music]